activist Kimberly Jones is getting
nationwide support for her powerful
video that compares the economic plight
of black Americans to a rigged game of
Monopoly her raw unscripted speech on
YouTube has been viewed more than two
million times and it's also been shared
by a number of celebrities from LeBron
James to Madonna
our national correspondent Rika Duncan
spoke with Jones about her important
message so for 400 rounds of Monopoly
you don't get to play at all not only do
you not get to play you have to play on
the behalf of the person that you're
playing against you have to play and
make money and earn wealth for them and
then you have to turn it over to them
Kimberly Jones's video titled how can we
win is part outrage part history lesson
she says for the 400 years since
enslaved Africans arrived in what is now
the United States they've been playing a
game stacked against them the Atlanta
based activists former bookseller and
young adult author has used the monopoly
analogy to teach finance and economics
to teenage girls but this was the first
time she used it to explain systemic
racism in such stark terms she also
referenced atrocities black communities
faced decades after slavery ended for 50
years you finally get a little bit and
you're allowed to play and every time
that they don't like the way that your
claim
that you're catching up or that you're
doing something to be self-sufficient
they burn your game you talk about Tulsa
you talk about rosewood these were
communities that were burned down by
white mobs in the 1920s yeah this idea
that we should just like pull ourselves
up by our bootstraps is ridiculous when
people are not ready to discuss the
ripple effects that slavery
reconstruction Jim Crow all of that has
had on our communities and they are
looking at what black people are looking
for is a quality and not revenge
Jones's passion is rooted in the numbers
black households earned just over forty
one thousand dollars per year compared
to $70,000 for non-hispanic whites and
black families have a median net worth
of seventeen thousand six hundred
dollars compared to one hundred seventy
one thousand dollars for white families
there was all of this systemic racism
that was allowed to just happen without
repercussion when people were building
the West's wealth but they could have
passed down generationally that was
taken from them
we're directed with that when we talk
about the economic disparagement of the
black community how do you do that well
I think the first thing is is to just
get the education that people need to
listen there's one person we saw this
week whose words have been echoing
around my head that captured a story
that so many people have struggled to
tell people are listening they're
understanding I think the next step is
to start to put in incremental plans
some form of restitution for these
communities whether you look at health
care education you know food insecurity
and when you say restitution what are
you talking about I'm gonna say the
tabie word that everybody hates
reparations I think we are old
reparations where do we go from here I
think that the best thing that we can do
is to get out and vote
but that's only step one we also need to
pull together our community and make
sure that the people that are on those
ballots are people that are from that
community that have the same desires for
that a community we need to have real
conversations we need real actionable
items about
next in order to see some real justice
and some real change in this nation does
this time feel different I think this
time feels very very different
particularly because it's happened on
such a global scale and I think people
have become passionate about it in a way
that we haven't seen since the civil
rights movement and I and I do think
that in five years we're gonna see a
healthier happier America Jones plans to
publish a book based on that video which
is more than 2 million views on YouTube
as of right now
she also said Gayle that she wants to
really work with people in her community
to groom candidates for local elections
she understands the power there with
people voting and said that's where she
also wants to make a change she's
already making a change first I can't
wait wait to read the book Jericka Ava
Duvernay sent me that video and I was
blown away by her eloquence and her
passion and the way she put it so
succinctly so so succinctly something
I'm not doing right now I think we all
need to take a class from Kimberly Jones
I'm so glad you talked to her yeah I
love to meet her Thank You Joo Rica